perret à propos de justice la
métamorphose des forces de l'ordre
policiers gendarmes les nouveaux
uniformes ont été présentés aujourd'hui
vous les découvrirez dans la rue ces
prochains mois le képi disparaît comme
la cravate fanni au vernis yannick à
rossi enfin l'endroit de la radio ont
cerné plan on l'a m suite au niveau de
l'arbre beau linge débat michelin de la
m mais mieux adapté au terrain policiers
et gendarmes découvert ce matin leur
nouvel uniforme voir l'armée tranquille
avant encore là dessous sont nombreux
talents ya la plaie à la gauche qui est
fait pour pantalon de type treillis
chaussures tout terrain et cette
casquette qui tient bien mieux sur la
tête que le képi quand il faut courir
tout a été repensé la cravate trop
facile à agripper a été supprimé la
sécurité n'a pas été oubliée clé a
remplacé le pull-over et gilet
pare-balles et mieux adapté en fait on
le sent pas bon 220 agents vont ainsi
être relooké pour un budget avoisinant
les 40 millions d'euros sur le terrain
on aura plus facilité de mouvement
on est plus à l'aise c'est plus sportif
en 1830 le sergent de ville est le
premier policier dotés d'un uniforme il
fallait qu'il soit reconnu mais l'habit
l'obligé aussi à une conduite morale ce
qui n'était pas toujours le cas
auparavant
l'un des uniformes les plus célèbres
c'est celui ci les l'hirondelle des
agents à vélo portant une cas
en deux siècles 12 uniforme se sont
ainsi succédé on s'étale et c'est la
maison de couture balenciaga qui a
relevé le défi six cultes et était de
dépoussiérer je pense à un uniforme qui
datait et de l'inclure dans le paysage
urbain le coût de cette nouvelle tenue
600 euros pièce pour les voir dans les
rues il faudra attendre le début d'année
désormais